Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio, genauer gesagt zum Chaosradio.
289, obwohl auch schon das nicht so genau klar ist, weil wir gerade ein bisschen
im Verzug sind, 289 oder 290,
wie dem auch sei, herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio, der Sendung,
wo wir uns grob einmal im Monat Dinge annehmen,
die irgendwas mit Technik oder digital zu tun haben, dann auseinandernehmen,
ganz von vorne anfangen und dann wieder so zusammensetzen, dass man sie,
wenn man Lust drauf hat, verstehen kann.
Und heute geht es um Bezahlkarten.
Und nein, wir reden nicht über Steam, Netflix oder irgendwas anderes,
Prepaid-Dinge, obwohl wir vielleicht auch fragen können, was die Gemeinsamkeiten
sind, sondern um ein neues Konzept, das ihr vielleicht gesehen habt,
wenn ihr Nachrichten verfolgt habt, das von der Politik gerade diskutiert wird,
Bezahlkarten für Geflüchtete.
Die sollen irgendwie Geldmittel durch Plastikkarten bekommen.
Was genau das bedeutet, wie der technische Hintergrund ist, warum der vielleicht
keine Rolle spielt und was man noch so darüber wissen kann, das besprechen wir heute hier.
Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Andrea Koten von Pro Asyl. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag. Du bist dort eine Referentin. Was macht eine Referentin genau?
Ja, auch eine Referentin beschäftigt sich mit spezifischen Themen und macht
Politik und Lobbyarbeit und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und schreibt Sachen und denkt
Sachen und macht noch einiges mehr.
All das und etwas davon heute vermutlich sowas wie eine rechliche Stunde hier im Chaosradio.
Außerdem eine Hälfte der Chefredaktion von Netzpolitik.org, Anna Wieseli, hallo. Hallo. Hallo.
Und wie hatten wir uns geeinigt?
Eine chaosnahe IT-Security-Entität namens Flüppke ist auch hier.
Hi, grüß dich. Guten Tag. Du hast schon Dinge auseinandergenommen,
unter anderem hast du dich mit der E-ID beschäftigt. Ja, zusammen.
Und interessierst dich für Sachen, die Technik beinhalten und die vielleicht
kaputt gehen können. Und vor allem, wenn da noch ein politischer Aspekt mit dazu kommt.
Der soll heute auf jeden Fall ausführlich diskutiert werden,
weil manche Sendungen sind ja so, ich weiß schon alles,
manche Sendungen sind so, ja in der letzten Zeit sind diese Schlagzeilen an
mir vorbeigegangen und so richtig genau habe ich es nicht verstanden,
aber ich hätte gerne mal, dass mir jemand erklärt und das ist heute für eine
Sendung für mich, die ich aus sehr großem Eigennutz also ausmache.
Umso leichter fällt es mir also heute wieder die Position für euch liebe Hörerinnen
einzunehmen und ganz am Anfang anzufangen zu fragen, Bezahlkarten,
was ist das eigentlich, was ist eine Bezahlkarte?
Also jetzt erstmal noch nicht für den konkreten Anwendungszweck,
sondern Bezahlkarte, was muss man sich darunter vorstellen, wer kann mir das sagen?
Naja, ich würde sagen, eine Bezahlkarte ist nicht mehr als eine Karte,
mit der ich bezahlen kann ohne Bargeld, also mit so Kartenzahlungen und das kann alles sein.
Eine Zählkarte und eine Kreditkarte ist schon auch eine Bezahlkarte.
So eine Bezahlkarte kann ja alles sein. Das ist ja auch das Problem.
Wir reden halt immer von Bezahlkarten in der Diskussion.
Aber was da wirklich dahinter steckt, darüber redet man halt zu wenig.
Und das war auch so, dass wenn ich irgendwie am Anfang darüber so Texte geschrieben
habe, dann kamen halt immer so ganz viele Kommentare von wegen so,
na aber ist doch gut, dass die jetzt auch mit Karte zahlen können.
Weil erstmal sagt der Begriff ja nichts. Deshalb ist er ja auch total gut geeignet
so in der politischen Diskussion.
Der ist ja nicht böse oder so. Also es geht ja jetzt gleich darum,
diese Bezahlkarten gibt es für Geflüchtete in Deutschland.
Und das ist aber sozusagen nicht ein feststehendes Konstrukt,
sondern verschiedene Orte, Bundesländer, was auch immer, verstehen darunter
verschiedene Dinge. Oder gibt es schon irgendwie so Gemeinsamkeiten,
wo man sagen kann, okay, das trifft schon zu.
Oder andersrum. Ich habe mir Folgendes vorgestellt. Die meisten Leute von uns,
wenn sie in Deutschland leben und reguläres Geld irgendwie haben, haben ein Girokonto.
Bei einem Girokonto kriegt man dann eine EC-Karte, da kann man im Supermarkt
bezahlen, am Bankautomat ein Geld abholen oder eine Kreditkarte,
damit kann man im Internet bezahlen oder auch Geld abholen.
Und ich dachte, so eine Bezahlkarte ist aber was anderes.
Ist das dann zu vergleichen mit so einem Prepaid-Ding?
Also man kann ja für viele Angebote, Amazon, Apple, was auch immer sozusagen,
Karten kaufen, da bezahlt man Geld und dann hat man auf einer Karte,
die letztlich eine Zahl, glaube ich, repräsentiert, einen Code,
hat man sozusagen Geld prepaid drauf. Ist das eine Bezahlkarte?
Ja, zumindest in dem Sinne, dass du, na die kannst du nicht überziehen,
wenn du jetzt deine, weiß ich nicht, Amazon-Gutscheinkarte kaufst,
dann kannst du damit ja nicht irgendwie ins Minus gehen,
das ist auch so eine Eigenschaft von den Bezahlkarten und du kannst da jetzt
nicht beliebig irgendwie Geld hin
und her überweisen, das ist auch eine Eigenschaft von den Bezahlkarten.
Aber als die jetzt auf einer politischen Ebene angefangen haben,
über Bezahlkarten zu reden, das heißt so letztes Jahr gegen Ende letzten Jahres,
da war noch überhaupt nicht klar, was das eigentlich genau sein soll und ob
man damit jetzt genauso bezahlen kann wie mit so einer EC-Karte,
die wir so kennen oder ob das irgendwie eingeschränkter ist,
wie es schon mal in den 90ern war. Da gab es das ja schon mal.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt eine Arbeitsgruppe,
was man halt immer macht.
Wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt, gründest du einen Arbeitskreis und so.
Und dann haben irgendwie die Länder und irgendwie noch der Deutsche Städtetag
und so ein paar wichtige Leute haben dann irgendwie Treffen gemacht und irgendwie
sich auf Mindeststandards,
sogenannte geeinigt, die aber irgendwie auch keine Mindeststandards sind,
weil da stand immer noch nicht genau drin, was das irgendwie sein soll.
Und ob du damit jetzt zum Beispiel Bargeld abheben kannst und wie viel und das
ist immer noch nicht klar für den konkreten Fall, beziehungsweise momentan ist
es so, dass viele schon angefangen haben, welche einzuführen,
das heißt, es gibt noch keine bundesweite existierende Lösung,
die soll es ja geben, aber stattdessen machen jetzt die Landkreise einen auf
irgendwie Wildwuchs und führen schon mal Bezahlkarten ein und die sind ganz, ganz unterschiedlich.
Da gibt es welche, mit denen kannst du Geld abheben, so viel du willst und wo
du willst, dann gibt es welche, mit denen kannst du in deinem...
Warte mal, stopp, du hast gesagt, so viel du willst.
Naja, so viel drauf ist, genau, ja. Aber jetzt nicht irgendwie nochmal künstlich eingeschränkt.
Oder es gibt auch welche, mit denen kannst du nur in einem bestimmten Postleitzahlbereich
bezahlen und auch irgendwie zum Beispiel nur 50 Euro vom Automaten holen pro Monat.
Und da gibt es einfach ganz, ganz viele Einschränkungen, die man darauf machen kann, aber nicht muss.
Ich hatte... Hallo, mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich denke mir möglichst einfache
Anstiegsfragen aus, die dann sofort scheitern.
Ich versuche sozusagen aber so einen Anfangspunkt zu finden,
vielleicht muss ich dann noch weiter zurückgehen.
Entschuldigung. Und fragen, also okay, wenn Bezahlkarte an sich gar nichts ganz
Konkretes ist, vielleicht aber sozusagen, dass jetzt bundesweit irgendwie eingeführt
werden sollte, vielleicht gibt es eine konkrete Idee dahinter.
Andrea, vielleicht kannst du uns das erzählen sozusagen. Was ist denn die Idee,
wenn ich jetzt sage, ich möchte Bezahlkarten einführen und jetzt,
da müssen wir vielleicht auch dazu, ich möchte bestimmte Bezahlkarten für Geflüchtete einführen.
Warum will ich denn das? Also welches Problem wird damit gelöst?
Ich will jetzt noch nicht darüber reden, ob es das wirklich so ist,
sondern die Leute, die sich das ausgedacht haben, welches Problem glauben die, wollen die damit lösen?
Das ist schon mal eine prima Frage. Einer hat das schon gesagt.
Naja, es ist prima, weil es unseres Erachtens natürlich zu dem Ergebnis führen
wird, dass dieses Problem, was da adressiert ist, mit dieser Lösung nicht gelöst
werden kann. Aber dazu kommen wir später.
Und flüchten und wo man sie unterbringen kann. Und aus dieser Debatte heraus,
die ja dann auch weitere Kreise zog, inhaltlich entwickelte sich dann auch das
Thema Sozialleistungen.
Das waren ursprünglich mal einzelne Stimmen aus der CDU und aus der FDP,
vor allen Dingen, die das Thema so eingebracht haben.
Vor allen Dingen der CSU-Chef Söder hat sich da sehr hervorgetan.
Er hat schon im August gesagt, wir müssen jetzt die finanziellen Anreize deutlich senken.
Er hat ganz früh dann auch schon über Bargeldentzug gesprochen Und die Bezahlkarte
dann ein bisschen später ins Spiel gebracht.
Insofern ist die Antwort auf deine Frage erstmal Anreize senken zum Ziele der
Reduzierung von Geflüchtetenzahlen, von Asylsuchendenzahlen in Deutschland.
Das war eigentlich das erste allgemein ausgerufene Ziel, aus dem heraus sich
diese Bezahlkartendebatte dann mehr und mehr entwickelt hat.
Okay, also wenn man ganz vorne anfängt, dann muss man jetzt also wahrscheinlich
eine Sache wissen, die ich jetzt vermute.
Das heißt, vorher war es so, Geflüchtete, die nach Deutschland kommen,
haben Anspruch auf irgendeine Art von Leistung und.
Diese Leistung wurde als Bargeld bis jetzt ausbezahlt? Nicht unbedingt.
Nicht unbedingt. Naja, also die Rede war davon, man wolle das Bargeld ersetzen.
Tatsächlich haben Geflüchtete schon immer nur einen Teil der ihnen zugedachten
Sozialleistungen als Bargeld bekommen.
Also sie kriegen zum einen Leistungen nach Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz, die geringer sind,
also unterhalb dessen liegen, was so Sozialempfänger in Deutschland kriegen
oder Bürgergeldempfänger in Deutschland kriegen Und von diesen Leistungen bekommen
sie in der Regel Pi mal Daumen maximal die Hälfte des Regelsatzes auch tatsächlich
als Geldleistung ausgezahlt.
Nicht zwingend als Barleistung, das kann auch eine Überweisung aufs Konto sein,
aber solange sie in der Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung der Länder wohnen,
wird da sehr viel gestellt.
Die bekommen ein Bett im Sammellager, sie bekommen eine Gemeinschaftsküche,
wo schon Töpfe drin sind.
Sie werden verwiesen auf die Kleiderkammer, die es da vor Ort gibt oder kriegen Gebrauchtkleidung.
Es gibt eine Vollverpflegung zu Beginn der Unterbringung jedenfalls.
Und all diese Sachleistungen werden von den Regelleistungen abgezogen und am
Ende bekommen sie jetzt nach jetzigem Stand vielleicht 204 Euro.
Überhaupt als Geldleistung, nicht unbedingt als Barleistung,
aber auch möglich als Barleistung am Anfang.
Also auch als Beispiel, du hast gerade so einen Nebensatz gesagt,
den ich nochmal nachfragen wollte, oder aufs Konto überwiesen.
Ja. Das ist ja, also so ein Konto eröffnen ist für uns trivial,
aber ist das für Geflüchtete, also haben Geflüchtete auch immer ein Konto oder ist.
Das ist in der Anfangszeit natürlich nicht.
Es dauert ein paar Wochen und dann haben sehr viele Geflüchtete ein ganz normales
Girokonto und die, die Schwierigkeiten haben, ein normales Girokonto zu bekommen,
weil sie die richtigen Ausweispapiere beispielsweise nicht vorlegen können dafür,
die haben auf jeden Fall das Recht, seit einigen Jahren ein sogenanntes Basiskonto zu eröffnen.
Das ist auch ein Guthabenkonto, was mit einer normalen Karte,
oh Gott, normale Karte kann ich gar nicht mehr sagen, nachdem wir die schon
so in Frage gestellt haben, die normale Karte, aber was mit einer Geldkarte verbunden ist.
Und das zumindest haben die allermeisten Geflüchteten dann eben nach einigen
Wochen. Und da finden natürlich auch Überweisungen statt.
Machen auch viele Kommunen so. Also die ursprüngliche Idee war,
Geflüchtete bekommen einen Teil, Teil der sowieso nicht so großen Leistungen
auch als Geld, entweder das Konto oder ein Bar.
Und das ist, so dachte die Politik oder so dachten die konservativen Anteile
der Politik, immer noch irgendwie so eine Art, deswegen kommen Leute her und
wenn wir das aufhören, dann kommen die nicht mehr her.
Das ist der Gedanke. Also so habe ich dich jetzt verstanden,
wenn ich es mal platt formulieren darf.
Ja, es kam aus genau dieser Debatte. Die Zahlen müssen runter.
Die Zahl der irregulären Flüchtlinge, es wurde dann immer auch gern mit so einem
Anstrich von Elektivität verbunden, dass die Leute hier sind,
diese Zahl müsse runter.
Das war die Oberüberschrift. Und dann hat man gesagt, Bargeld ist da ein Pullfaktor.
Die Leute kommen deshalb hierher, weil es hier Bargeld gibt und weil sie dieses
Bargeld dann in die Heimat schicken können.
Wie sie denn Bargeld in die Heimat schicken können, muss ich mich jetzt glaube
ich nicht darüber auslassen, auf welchen Wegen man Bargeld verschickt,
weil es geht ja in der Regel dann doch auch per Überweisung.
Aber das waren so die Begründungen, die am Anfang im Raum standen und dann kam
dazu, dass man gesagt hat, ja wir wollen auch die Verwaltungsabläufe vereinfachen mit so einer Karte.
Drüber reden nochmal. Das ist vielleicht nochmal ein besonderer Punkt.
Es war nicht eigentlich der Anlass dafür.
Eigentlich stand immer drüber, die Zahlen müssen runter, wir wollen abschrecken,
wir wollen es den Leuten ungemütlich machen.
Wir wollen ihnen Verfügungsmöglichkeiten entziehen, sodass weniger Leute hierher kommen.
Ich würde trotzdem sagen, auf das andere nochmal ganz kurz zu sprechen kommen,
weil es ist ja oft so, wenn man irgendwas einführt, wird, was auch nur den Anschein
von Digitalheit sagt, das macht Dinge einfacher, man spart den Verwaltungsaufwand.
Und das könnte man natürlich wirklich denken, wenn Leute sozusagen irgendwo
hingehen müssen, um sich dort Geld in physikalischer Form abzuholen,
das muss dann ausgezahlt werden, muss ein Buch geführt werden und so weiter
und so fort, dass es vielleicht tatsächlich einfacher ist, wenn,
und da redet es nicht, ob das sinnvoll ist, dass es kein Girokonto ist,
sondern eine Bezahlkarte, aber dass es tatsächlich Dinge einfacher macht. Und.
Ist natürlich sofort auch der Verdacht, naja, wenn das eigentliche Ziel war,
Deutschland unattraktiv zu machen, ist das vielleicht nur so ein Feigenblatt-Argument.
Wie dick ist denn das Feigenblatt? Also lässt sich Verwaltungsaufwand damit
tatsächlich irgendwie nachweisbar vermindern?
Gibt es da Dinge, Anna? Ich würde sagen, es gibt einen Fall,
wo es sinnvoll wäre, eine Bezahlkarte einzusetzen.
Das heißt, eine Person kommt nach Deutschland, eine Person registriert sich.
Hat noch kein Konto, weder ein normales, in Anführungszeichen,
Girokonto, noch so ein Basiskonto und braucht Geld.
So, das heißt, du bist irgendwie registriert, dann hast du einen Anspruch und
dann stehst du irgendwie beim Amt und dann müssen die ja irgendwas machen und
dann könnten sie dir Bargeld geben.
Das wäre eine Option, aber auf der anderen Seite so aus einer persönlichen Sicht,
ich kann es verstehen, dass das Amt irgendwie keine Lust hat,
da auch ganz viel Bargeld rumliegen zu haben, ist ja auch irgendwie nicht geil
so und das irgendwie jeden Monat zu handeln.
Das heißt für so eine Übergangszeit, das heißt eine Person kommt an,
registriert sich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Person dann so ein Basiskonto,
Girokonto, was auch immer hat,
würde ich sagen, total super Sache kann man machen, wenn die Person damit so normal umgehen kann.
Dass sie jetzt da irgendwie nicht überziehen soll, meinetwegen alles fein und
da könnte man den Verwaltungsaufwand reduzieren.
Aber jetzt wird jetzt total ad absurdum geführt, weil eigentlich ist ja die
Idee, dass die Leute dann nicht mehr da jeden Monat auch auftauchen müssen.
So hat ich das verstanden, ja.
Okay. Damit entlastest du halt niemanden. Da hast du kein Bargeld mehr rumliegen,
das ist schön, das ist dann das Einzige, was du erreicht hast,
aber ansonsten hast du halt nichts gewonnen.
Wir sind jetzt irgendwie noch nicht mal eine Viertelstunde, glaube ich,
in der Sendung und schon jetzt scheint mir das Projekt so absurd,
dass ich mich frage, warum gibt es das überhaupt noch? Das habe ich mir auch schon gefragt.
Okay, gibt es da Vermutungen? Also jetzt außer, dass Leute glauben,
dass man es dort... Also, vielleicht zur Ehrenrettung der Stadt Hannover,
Die hat ja diese Bezahlkarten auch
eingeführt mit dem Argument Verwaltungsvereinfachung und Digitalisierung.
Und da funktioniert es genauso, wie Anna es beschrieben hat,
für eine sinnvolle Übergangszeit.
Die Leute kommen, haben noch kein Konto und für diese Zeit, in der sie noch
kein Konto haben, bekommen sie die Bezahlkarte ohne alle Beschränkungen.
Also es funktioniert, es ist eine Debitkarte auf Guthabenbasis.
Überziehungen sind nicht möglich, aber sie bekommen automatisch das Geld überwiesen,
können den Gesamtbetrag abheben, können Überweisungen in unbeschränkter Form
vornehmen und sobald die Betroffenen dann ein Konto haben,
ist die Bezahlkarte dann auch wieder weg und dann gibt es eine ganz normale Überweisung.
Und in so einer Ausgestaltung würden auch wir sagen, ja, da macht es Sinn.
Die Verwaltung in Hannover hat vorgerechnet, dass sie dadurch Geld spart,
letztlich Personalaufwand spart und tatsächlich Verwaltung spart, so wie sie das machen.
Und den Betroffenen kommt es auch entgegen. Insofern sind wir da auch nicht
gegen Digitalisierung an dem Punkt, sondern finden es genau für diesen Zeitraum sinnvoll.
Aber die Idee, haben wir ja drüber gesprochen, die Idee ist ja eigentlich eine
andere und die meisten Kommunen haben was ganz anderes vor.
Also es ist wie so oft mit so Technik-Hype-Themen, aber im Kleinen habe ich
das Gefühl, es gibt sehr eng fokussierte Anwendungsfälle, wo das Sinn macht
und dann kommen Leute und sagen, nein, wir machen einfach alles damit und zwar immer.
Und das ist der Punkt, Flippke, wo ich dich dann fragen wollen würde,
ein bisschen über diese technische Seite.
Also Bargeld ist jetzt technisch relativ unkompliziert, also bei der Erstellung
nicht, aber beim Transfer, Ausgeben und so weiter und so fort.
Wenn ich es habe, kann ich es ausgeben und so weiter und so fort.
Bei Plastikkarten, also EC-Karten und Visa-Karten und Überweisungen gibt es
schon mehrere Chaosradios, dass das auch ein technisch interessantes Feld ist.
Wo es aber zumindest ein Konzept davon gibt, wie man das sicher machen kann.
Das passiert dann oft genug nicht und wir verweisen hier gerne auf die alten
Folgen, aber im Prinzip gibt es da sowas.
Jetzt hat man mit Bezahlkarten sich was Neues ausgedacht, einen Zwischenschritt
und das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht so ganz, ob das dann technisch auch was anderes ist.
Und kannst du das erklären, ist das im Prinzip auch nur eine Visa-Karte und
man hat das dann irgendwie künstlich beschnitten oder ist das eher so,
jemand denkt sich was aus und das ist im Prinzip wie in so einer Firma, gibt es ja manchmal,
wenn man kopieren geht, hat man so eine kleine Plastikkarte,
die muss man dann in den Kopierer halten, da wird gezählt, wie viele Kopieren
man gemacht hat und das ist technisch, weil es um Kopien geht,
dann irgendwie nicht so doll aufwendig und auch nicht so doll sicher, was passiert?
Also ich muss noch mal fragen, was ist Bezahlkarte? Ich weiß schon,
die Antwort ist, es gibt kein einzelnes Konzept, aber was ist die gemacht?
Es gibt schon ein einheitliches Konzept inzwischen,
das kann man nämlich so ein bisschen aus der Ausschreibung, aus der bundesweiten
Ausschreibung für die Bezahlkarte ableiten, was da so die technischen Anforderungen
oder Implementationen sein werden.
Die sind allerdings auch noch leider relativ unklar und die genauen Details
bekommt man auch nur, wenn man da an der Ausschreibung teilnimmt und in die
engere Auswahl gezogen wird. Hast du noch nicht versucht mal an der Ausschreibung?
Leider bin ich kein Kartenzahlungsdienstleister und habe auch kein Interesse
daran, mit so einer Lösung Geld zu verdienen.
Es gibt, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, ganz unterschiedliche Implementationen
in den unterschiedlichen Landkreisen. Und da sind natürlich jetzt gerade,
ich sag's mal, dreist viele Glücksritter unterwegs, die da irgendwie probieren, Geld mitzuverdienen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die Karten trotzdem den Kreisen,
den Kommunen Geld sparen könnten, weil Bargeldhandling ist halt technisch ziemlich
einfach, aber halt kompliziert und teuer tatsächlich.
Man muss halt da sich irgendwie so Tresorräume zulegen, man braucht Wachschutz,
Bargeldtransporte sind teuer.
Die meisten Implementationen, die ich jetzt bisher gesehen habe,
die basieren darauf, dass da ein Fintech dahinter steht und das eine normale
Kreditkarte ausstellt am Ende des Tages, die allerdings rein Debit basiert ist.
Das heißt, es ist eine Guthaben-basierte Karte.
Dahinter steht meistens irgendwie noch so eine IBAN, auf die dann eine Kommune
irgendwie Geld überweisen kann.
Das ist kein Konto, auf das eine geflohene Person irgendwie Zugriff hat.
Die bekommt nur eine Plastikkarte in die Hand gedrückt und das verhält sich
dann gegenüber einem Kartenzahlungsterminal beim Merchant, also sprich im Supermarkt
dann wie eine normale Debitkarte. EC-Karten gibt es übrigens nicht mehr.
Kreditkarten sind ein super Thema, in das man sich rein nerden kann.
Okay, dann müssen wir vielleicht dazu nochmal eine Update-Sendung machen.
Aber verstehe ich dich gerade richtig?
Die Bezahlkarten sind nicht so, dass man sich dann vielleicht die Hände reiben
kann und sagen, haha, ein neues technisches Konstrukt, mal schauen,
was sie da verbrochen haben.
Sondern im Hintergrund, also unter der Haube sozusagen, werkelt da das ganz
normale deutsche Bankensystem mit den ganz normalen Plastikkarten,
die irgendwie Geld von schief nach schräg schrieben.
Und da gibt es eigentlich sozusagen gar nichts Neues?
Richtig, also dadurch wird halt... Bedeutend.
Naja, es ist schon sinnvoll, das tatsächlich aus technischer Perspektive so
anzugehen. Denn wenn man jetzt ein komplett neues Bezahlungsmittel einführen
würde, dann wäre die Akzeptanz natürlich absolut null.
Und das wäre natürlich eine riesengroße Katastrophe. Es ist ja auch jetzt schon
so, dass man mit Kreditkarten nicht an besonders vielen Orten irgendwie bezahlen kann.
Also gerade wenn ich mir irgendwie so Berlin vorstelle, da ist man halt ohne
Bargeld echt aufgeschmissen.
Aber technisch ist das eigentlich relativ langweilig.
Da gibt es dann halt ein Social Card oder andere Anbieter, GIF ist zum Beispiel auch noch ein Produkt.
Und das sind dann meistens Anbieter, die entweder schon so im Bezahlkartengeschäft
drin sind, die dann Bezahlkarten sollt MitarbeiterInnen-Benefit rausgeben,
womit du dann zum Beispiel tanken kannst.
Aber im Grunde genommen ist das am Ende des Tages halt einfach eine Kreditkarte,
eine Debitkarte, mit der du halt normal bezahlen kannst.
Das Besondere hier ist, dass die Anbieter dann halt noch Restriktionen darauf einführen.
Und da ist es dann halt interessant. Interessant und es gibt ja einen schönen
Begriff von Cory Doctorow, glaube ich, geprägt Entschädification.
Also sagen, es gibt ein technisches Ding, das kann eigentlich alles und dann
kommt jemand und sagt, nee,
darfst du aber nicht, weil ich verbiete dir das und dann kann man es irgendwie
freischalten für Premium-Abo oder ich bin in den Staat und du darfst nicht,
weil ich will nicht und du sollst eigentlich gar nicht mehr zu mir kommen.
Ich verstehe das richtig.
Es ist eigentlich sozusagen, könnte das alles eine ganz normale Debitkarte wie
du und ich haben sein, aber das wird technisch angeschränkt.
Kann man das künstlich beschränken?
Wenn ich irgendwo in einem Geschäft bezahle, dann hat dieser Merchant ja irgendwie
so ein Terminal, so ein Point of Sale und in dem Ding steht drinne,
was das für ein Merchant ist.
Sodass man zum Beispiel Tabakwarenläden ausschließen kann und sagen kann,
nö, da darfst du nicht bezahlen.
Oder die Funktion auf bestimmte Postleitzahlengebiete beschränken kann.
Oder zum Beispiel Online-Zahlungen unterbinden kann. Oder die Verwendung mit
PayPal unterbinden kann.
Und aus den Ausschreibungen und aus den Anforderungskatalogen geht auch klar
hervor, dass sie versuchen, irgendwelche Schlupflöcher möglichst abzulegen,
zuzumachen und nicht offen zu lassen. Aber da kommt doch jemand,
der eine Chaos-Security-Entität ist.
Also wenn Sie sagen, da ist ein System, das ist künstlich eingeschränkt,
da ist doch wahrscheinlich der Impuls dazu, gucken, aber kann man diese künstliche
Einschränkung nicht vielleicht so ein bisschen... Ja, genau richtig.
Das ist sicherlich ein spannendes Forschungsfeld, wobei man da aufpassen muss
mit der Weitergabe von Karten, dass man da nicht eine geflohene Person plötzlich
irgendwie in juristische Schwierigkeiten bringt, in einer ohnehin schon schwierigen Situation.
Aber wie gesagt, das sind halt meistens irgendwelche Fintechs,
die halt darauf spezialisiert sind, Kreditkartengeschäft zu machen.
Das heißt, deren Aufgabe ist, da die Technik irgendwie hinzubekommen.
Die bieten das meistens irgendwie so als White-Label-Lösung an und werden dann
von irgendwelchen, ich sage es nochmal dreist, Glücksrittern beauftragt,
die dann irgendwie ein Web-Frontend davor klöppeln für die Verwaltung,
dass die dann da Karten ausstellen können und da irgendwelche Beschränkungen
drauf implementieren können.
Also ganz konkretes Beispiel für solche Beschränkungen, ja, Alkohol hatte ich
eben schon erwähnt, Glücksspiel zum Beispiel könnte auch unterbunden werden.
Und das sind alles Einschränkungen, die man beim Bargeld nicht hätte.
Auch Bargeldabhebungen können natürlich eingeschränkt werden.
Genau, aber du kannst ja auch nicht Alkohol ganz einschränken,
das ist ja auch so das, das ist ja das, was irgendwie der Söder kam ja am Anfang
mit irgendwie hier Leberkäse ja, irgendwie Alkohol nein,
das ist ja so dieses Ding, aber das ist halt auch so Bullshit,
also es gibt halt diese Merchant Category Codes, die sind nicht für jeden Anbieter
gleich, aber Visa hat zum Beispiel so eine lange Liste, die kann man sich auch im Internet angucken.
Und dann kann man sich halt angucken, welche Kategorien gibt es und welche kann ich sperren.
Also alle, die es gibt, kann ich sperren, die, die es nicht gibt,
kann ich halt nicht sperren.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, die du zum Beispiel hast, ist, wenn du irgendwelche
Bars und so Nachtclubs und Diskotheken haben einen eigenen Code.
Das heißt, da kann ich sagen, okay, ich will nicht, dass die Person in der Disse
irgendwie Alkohol kaufen kann.
Kannst aber nicht sagen. Das heißt, sie kann dann aber in diesem ganzen Assemblissement
nicht bezahlen. Genau, korrekt. Aber du kannst jetzt nicht sagen oder nicht
sinnvoll sagen, ich schließe jetzt irgendwie den generellen Lebensmitteleinzelhandel aus.
Also könntest du schon, aber dann können die Leute keine Lebensmittel mehr kaufen.
Und du kannst aber nicht ausschließen, dass die Leute im generellen Lebensmitteleinzelhandel
sich irgendwie eine Flasche Bier holen.
Das geht nicht, weil du siehst ja nicht, was genau sie kaufen und du kannst
nur den Händler generell ausschließen. Du kannst zum Beispiel auch Schneemobilhändler
ausschließen, dann kannst du sicherstellen, dass sich irgendwie Geflüchtete
in Deutschland kein Schneemobil beim Schneemobilhändler kaufen. Das geht.
Oder dass sie in so einem Spezialitäten-Alkoholladen einkaufen gehen,
wo sie das Geld nicht für haben. Aber du kannst halt nicht sagen,
hier bei Lidl darfst du kein Bier kaufen.
Aber wir haben jetzt die technische Machbarkeit dieser Restriktionen gelernt
und auch gelernt, dass sie nur begrenzt sind, von einsetzbar sind,
aber was wird denn damit gemacht?
Also man will den Leuten ja das Leben schwer machen, das ist ja die Motivation
dahinter, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, damit Deutschland unattraktiv wird.
Wie wird das versucht? Gibt es da jetzt Anwendungsfälle?
Na ja, zum Beispiel, dass du halt irgendwie nur einen bestimmten Bargeldbetrag
im Monat abheben kannst.
Das heißt, so 50 Euro sind so, glaube ich, das, was Bayern irgendwie vorhat
und was auch irgendwie in anderen Landkreisen schon gemacht wird.
Dann sagst du, okay, von deinem wenigen Geld, also von deinen meistens so 200
Euro oder weniger pro Monat, darfst du nur 50 Euro Bar holen. Und dann sollst du…,
Weiß ich nicht, was da irgendwie... Oder du darfst nur so und so viele Transaktionen
in einer Woche machen und die dürfen maximal diesen oder jenen Betrag haben.
In so einer Musterausschreibung, die praktischerweise so ein Bezahlkartenanbieter
selber geschrieben hat, die haben da natürlich auch ein Threadmodel drin.
Das heißt, die haben sich überlegt, was für Schlupflöcher kann es da irgendwie
geben. Eben da ist dann die Rede von Gemüsehändlern, die sich auf Bargeldauszahlungen
spezialisieren könnten,
um dann halt da Bargeld statt irgendwelcher Waren oder Dienstleistungen auszuhändigen.
Warte, die Idee ist, es gibt Gemüsehändler, zu denen gehe ich mit meiner Bezahlkarte,
kaufe eine Gurke und bekomme das Wechselgeld in Bar?
Nee, du kriegst nur Geld. Du kriegst dann nur Geld. Also die haben das da so
in Quote Quote Gemüsewarenhändler.
Und deswegen darf ich dann nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Transaktionen haben,
wenn ich nicht Gemüsehändlere.
Richtig. Ja, aber das gab es ja wirklich. Das haben die sich ja nicht ausgedacht.
Also wir hatten ja schon mal Bezahlkarten in Berlin zum Beispiel, in den 90ern.
Da war das noch so ein bisschen anders und da konnte man noch nicht so viel automatisiert machen.
Und ich glaube, von der Einführung, bis sie quasi die ersten Gemüsehändler gefunden haben,
die dann halt irgendwie sich darauf spezialisieren, den Leuten von dieser Karte
Geld zu tauschen, gegen eine Provision von schlappen 10 Prozent,
die dann beim Gemüsehändler bleiben,
hat es glaube ich eineinhalb Wochen gedauert, bis die ersten Leute halt angefangen
haben zu bescheißen und mit dem Leid von den Leuten und mit der Scheiße,
in der sie sitzen, auch noch Geld zu verdienen.
Also mal abgesehen davon, dass dem Tür und Tor geöffnet wird,
Andrea, würde ich gerne fragen, pro Asyl setze ich ja für die Rechte von Geflüchteten
ein und ich habe tatsächlich die rechtliche Frage dahinter,
wenn, also du hast ja vorhin gesagt, es gibt ein, wie heißt das,
Asyl, wo diese Leistung, genau
das Leistungsgesetz, ist das denn überhaupt zulässig, dass sich Leute,
dass das dann in einem Gesetz steht, die Leute sollen Geld haben und dann,
okay, ich stelle denen was zur Verfügung, Das verrechne ich damit.
Finde ich schon fishy, aber okay.
Aber dass man dann sozusagen noch darüber hinaus das Geld, das denen ausgezahlt
werden soll, dass man das so einschränkt, darf man das überhaupt?
Also das ist ja eine rechtliche Frage, wenn ich dich richtig verstehe.
Vielleicht habt ihr da mal geguckt, ob man auch in der Richtung was machen kann.
Also es gibt dieses Leistungsgesetz für Geflüchtete, das gibt es jetzt seit 30 Jahren.
Und das ist seinerzeit, 1993 ist das eingeführt worden.
Und man glaubt mich, mit welcher Begründung? Ja, mit der gleichen Begründung,
mit der jetzt Bezahlkarten eingeführt werden.
Mega sympathisch. Genau, es soll verhindern, das hatte ich heute noch nicht
erwähnt, dass Schleuser bezahlt werden können.
Es soll eine abschreckende Wirkung entfalten. Das war das erklärte Ziel des
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetzes von Anfang an.
Und in diesem Leistungsgesetz ist jetzt erstmal festgelegt, dass Menschen unabhängig
vom Aufenthaltsstatus,
solange sie noch keinen Anspruch auf reguläre Sozialleistung haben,
eben auch Rechte haben und Sozialleistung bekommen nach diesem Gesetz.
Diese Leistungen sind, ich habe es schon gesagt, niedriger als das,
was normale Sozialhilfeempfänger bekommen oder Bürgergeldempfänger bekommen
und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich mehrfach schon zu diesen Leistungen
geäußert, nicht zuletzt, sondern vor allen Dingen 2012 in einem sehr wichtigen Urteil.
Weil da hat das Verfassungsgericht gesagt, jeder Mensch in Deutschland hat das
Recht auf ein menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum und das leitet das Gericht ab
aus dem Artikel 1 der Menschenwürde und aus dem Artikel 20 dem Sozialstaat.
Das heißt, das Recht auf ein menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum ist ein Grundrecht
und es ist ein Menschenrecht.
Und dann hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht damals auch in diesem schönen Urteil
den Satz geprägt, die Menschenwürde ist migrationspolitisch nicht zu relativieren.
Das kann man übersetzen, indem man sagt, Sozialleistungen dürfen nicht eingesetzt
werden, um migrationspolitische Ziele zu verfolgen.
Also Sozialleistungen dürfen nicht zur Abschreckung missbraucht werden.
Und das beantwortet meines Erachtens die Frage, die du gestellt hast,
dürfen die das eigentlich?
Nein, meines Erachtens dürfen, unseres Erachtens dürfen Sozialleistungen nicht
so gestaltet werden, dass sie abschrecken sollen.
Da ist eigentlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht davor, würde ich so sagen.
Genau das soll ja mit der Bezahlkarte hier passieren, die Zahlen runterzukriegen.
Auch wenn man sagt, man soll keine Schlepper bezahlen und so weiter.
Also damals hat man ein Sonderrecht geschaffen und damals hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht
auch gesagt, die Leistungen sind evident zu niedrig und haben sie erstmal hochgesetzt.
Das war 2015 und danach hat man wieder angefangen, wieder neue Beschränkungen zu machen.
Und bis man jetzt, wenn man jetzt sagen würde, das, was jetzt neu eingeführt
wird, das widerspricht erneut dem Verfassungsrecht, das widerspricht dem Gedanken,
dann müsste man wieder ein neues Verfahren beginnen und der Weg zum Verfassungsgericht ist sehr lang.
Es ist noch ein Verfassungsgerichtsurteil offen, es ist noch ein Verfahren anhängig,
das auch darüber entscheiden wird, ob dieses gesamte Grundleistungssystem,
auch die Höhe der Leistung im Moment, das Sachleistungssystem,
wie es im Augenblick funktioniert,
ob das überhaupt verfassungsgemäß ist und da haben wir noch keine Entscheidung dazu.
Fantastisch. Das ist eine Idee, die ist gar nicht so geil zu,
eigentlich bräuchten wir wieder das Bundesverfassungsgericht,
hat es ja nicht sehr lange gedauert.
Ist das jetzt so der alles anzünden Moment wieder?
Ja, also was ich mich vor allen Dingen gerade frage ist, mir erscheint das Thema
gar nicht so mega komplex, weil es gibt diese Bausteine der Security, Security, die sind,
also kann man, wenn man sich mit Bezahlsystemen, aber es gibt ja nichts Neues.
Es gibt die, es gibt den Baustein der politischen Motivation,
der ist menschenverachtend, wenn ich das mal so für mich sagen darf und könnte
vom Bundesverfassungsgericht handeln.
Ich frage mich sozusagen, warum reden wir hier drüber?
Es gibt ja sozusagen oft Dinge, die sind so ein bisschen unklar und da kann
man nachvollziehen irgendwie, wo das herkommt und da gibt es vielleicht doch
was, wie man das gut machen kann, aber Aber das sehe ich hier überhaupt nicht.
Nee, das ganze Thema ist total Stulle, ehrlich gesagt. Also das ist irgendwie,
das ist auch das, was mich so aufregt daran, weil ich mir denke,
die haben ja gesagt, okay, wir wollen die Leute abschrecken.
Und auch das, dass sowas überhaupt, wenn man das annehmen würde,
so ich finde das richtig scheiße und ich finde das irgendwie unmenschlich und kacke.
Aber selbst wenn man dieses Ziel akzeptieren würde, es gibt null Belege dafür, dass das funktioniert.
Also das ist auch vollkommen absurd zu sagen, okay, ich bin eine Person,
die steht vor der Situation aus, ihrem Zuhause oder ihrer Heimat flüchten zu müssen.
Denkst du, es ist realistisch, dass irgendjemand sich hinsetzt und dann irgendwie
sagt, ach nee, Mensch, in Deutschland,
da kriege ich ja jetzt so eine Karte, das habe ich irgendwie gehört und dann
gehe ich jetzt nicht los oder woanders hin oder so.
Das ist ja nicht so, als würdest du dann irgendwie so auf dem Booking-Portal
irgendwie nach 4- und 5-Sterne-Bewertungen sortieren, um zu gucken,
wo du hingehst. Das macht ja keiner aus Spaß.
Und wenn ich das sagen darf, die Politiker, die können es natürlich auch immer einfach mal probieren.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass, weil das Verfassungsgericht irgendwas sagt und sagt,
hier Menschenwürde und das verstößt dagegen oder weil Pro Asyl das sagt.
Da schrecken die Politiker davor zurück. Sondern sie sagen, wir probieren es
mal, wir lassen es mal darauf ankommen.
Und es dauert Jahre, bis man irgendwann vom Verfassungsgericht landet.
Und dann ist das Ergebnis ja auch nicht, wir können es ja auch nicht vorwegnehmen.
Also mit der Form der Leistung zum Beispiel hat sich das Verfassungsgericht
gar nicht explizit auseinandergesetzt und hat gesagt,
ob es grundsätzlich, ob dieses Existenzminimum gedeckt wird,
jetzt durch Geldleistung, durch Sachleistung oder durch Dienstleistung,
das kann grundsätzlich der Gesetzgeber selber entscheiden.
Und da sagen sie natürlich, ja dann machen wir das doch auch so,
dann probieren wir es doch aus, lassen uns darauf ankommen.
Das Problem ist nur, es darf keine Unterdeckung geben.
Was ist eine Unterdeckung?
Also die Menschen müssen am Ende das bekommen, was ihnen zusteht, das, was sie brauchen.
Das müssen sie bekommen am Ende. Und wir wissen das ja aus den Erfahrungen der
Vergangenheit oder auch aus den aktuellen Sachleistungserfahrungen.
Wenn man in einer Unterkunft wohnt mit einem kleinen Kind und man braucht ein
Aufwärmgerät für Babyfläschchen. Es gibt aber keine.
Aber es gibt stattdessen einen Wasserkocher. Was nützt mir der Wasserkocher?
Dann kriege ich eine Sachleistung, aber ich kriege nicht das,
was ich brauche. Ja, weil ich das Geld nicht zur Verfügung habe,
zu entscheiden, dass ich mein Geld nicht für einen Wasserkocher brauche,
sondern für meinen Babyfläschchenwärmer.
Und so funktioniert im Endeffekt das Sachleistungsprinzip so,
dass am Ende die Leute nicht bekommen, was sie wollen.
Wir haben das sehr lange analysiert. Der Georg Claßen vom Berliner Flüchtlingsrat,
der hat ein dickes Buch darüber geschrieben, auf dem Verfassungsgericht zur Verfügung gestellt.
Eine Analyse dieser Regelsätze, wie das funktioniert. Und das ist ja unsere
Befürchtung, dass diese Bezahlkarte mit den ganzen Einschränkungen,
die alle auf der Wunschliste der Länder stehen,
diese Möglichkeiten Bargeldeinschränkungen, keine Überweisung,
kein Überweisung ins Ausland, alles das, was da draufsteht, dass das am Ende
dazu führt, dass die Leute nicht in der Lage sind, das zu bekommen,
was ihnen von Rechts wegen zusteht.
Aber das nachzuweisen wird halt ein langer Weg.
Das ist aber tatsächlich eine Frage, die ich hatte, weil es gibt ja so ein Konzept,
das ich Investoren sozusagen gesehen habe.
Also die Leute arbeiten für eine große Company in so einer Goldgräberstadt und
werden dann in Geld bezahlt, das sie aber nur in Läden ausgeben können,
die dieser Company gehören.
Und wir haben jetzt ein bisschen über diese Restriktionen gesprochen,
das gerade mit den Sachleistungen das angeht.
Ist das auch ein Konstrukt, das irgendwo vielleicht schon in der Luft schwebt,
dass die Leute sagen, naja, wir wollen nicht nur verbieten, dass sie in die
Disco gehen, sondern eigentlich hätten wir es am liebsten, wenn die nur bei
ganz bestimmten Läden ihr Geld ausgeben können.
Das ist total großartig. Einer der Hersteller, was ich so den Peak-Zynismus
fand, was ich irgendwie gesehen habe, die haben auf ihrer Webseite damit Werbung gemacht,
dass dadurch, dass quasi der Postleitzahlenbereich eingeschränkt wird,
in dem die Leute damit bezahlen können, dass das Geld in der Region bleibt und
damit kannst du heimische Wirtschaftsförderung machen. Das ist richtig geil.
Das musst du erstmal ausdenken. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man jetzt so ein
Dein-Western-Szenario sehe ich noch nicht.
Ich bin überrascht sozusagen, dass niemand zynisch genug war,
um sich das auszudenken.
Aber auch so aus technischer Perspektive, das nachzuweisen, dass da bestimmte
Sachleistungen jetzt nicht erbracht wurden oder irgendwelche Sachen,
die einem Klonen zustehen würden.
Im Zweifelsfall, selbst wenn es ein komplett freizügiges System wird,
besteht ja zum Beispiel immer noch die Möglichkeit,
dass irgendeine Sachbearbeiterin, irgendein Sachbearbeiter einfach Klickkarte
sperren drückt und sagt, ja und du stehst dann da irgendwo so vom Terminal und
das wird dann zum Glücksspiel, ob die Karte jetzt akzeptiert wird oder nicht.
Ich meine, man kennt das ja von Kartenzahlungen im Ausland.
Da ist es halt lästig, wenn irgendwie die Kreditkarte mal rejected oder gesperrt wird.
Aber da ist man dann halt noch viel mehr der Willkür der Behörden ausgesetzt,
die dann da irgendein Webfrontend haben, wo sie halt Restriktionen klicken können
oder die Karte sperren können.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine Anforderung, die stand eigentlich fast überall mit
drin, dass es möglich sein muss, die Karte zu sperren durch die Behörde und
auch Restguthaben wieder zurückzuholen.
Wie sieht denn dann das in Audit-Log aus, dass die Karte gesperrt wurde und aus welchem Grund?
Wie wird da Willkür verhindert? Ja, das sehen wir auch so.
Sie schreiben natürlich dazu,
dass sie dann für den Fall des Verlusts der Karte das vorsehen wollen.
Aber wir kennen ja die Realität. Das, was Anna vorhin beschrieben hat,
dass die Leute antanzen sollen.
Weil wenn sie dann nicht antanzen, wenn Geflüchtete sich nicht regelmäßig bei
den Behörden blicken lassen oder wenn man sie nötigen will, sich da blicken
zu lassen, dann ist das halt ein Druckmittel, das sie in der Hand haben.
Sie könnten auch einfach sagen, oh, zwei Tage nicht in der Unterkunft.
Wir haben das schon erlebt, da werden Leute von der Unterkunft abgemeldet.
Die sind ja nicht mehr da.
Also werden sie abgemeldet, auch wenn sie vielleicht nur beim Freund geschlafen haben.
Wer sagt uns eigentlich, dass da nicht ein Sozialamt sagt, die Leute sind ja
offenkundig ausgereist oder halten sich nicht da auf, wo sie sollen.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, das soll ja ein Bargeldersatz sein,
aber der Vergleich hängt auch an dieser Stelle, weil nämlich jederzeit ein Sachbearbeiter
quasi ins Pockmanni greifen kann und sagen kann, nein,
das ist zwar dein Guthaben, aber das hast du gar nicht mehr.
Das wäre natürlich rechtswidrig, wenn sie das täten.
Aber es ist trotzdem damit zu rechnen, dass das passiert, wie auch immer.
Also wenn es halt einmal irgendwo so technische Lösungen gibt,
dann ist halt ein Missbrauch davon schwierig zu unterbinden.
So in den Portalen, wo ich das jetzt bisher gesehen habe, war da kein Vier-Augen-Prinzip,
da konnte es halt einfach Klick, Karte gesperrt und dann war nichts mehr mit Geld ausgeben.
Und zusätzlich ist auch möglich, dass nicht nur dir das Portemonnaie weggenommen
wird, sondern halt auch da eine Sachbearbeiterin dir ins Portemonnaie reinschaut
und noch gucken kann, wie viel Geld hast du eigentlich noch.
Was wir zum Glück, ich zumindest bisher noch nicht gesehen habe,
ist, dass SachbearbeiterInnen die Transaktionshistorie tatsächlich einsehen
können. Das wäre aber tatsächlich meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich mit dem Datenschutz aus? Also weil ich fühle mich
auch so ein bisschen an die ganz generelle Diskussion Bargeld versus elektronisches
Geld, in welcher Form auch erinnert.
Das wäre natürlich der nächste Schritt gewesen,
Wenn du einerseits sagen kannst, du unterbinden, dass in bestimmten Händler-Kategorien
gekauft wird, aber diese Daten fallen ja irgendwie an.
Ist das irgendwie besonders geregelt, wer dann darauf Zugriff haben darf?
Also wahrscheinlich ist die Antwort auch hier wieder, es gibt verschiedene Anbieter
und so weiter und so fort, aber im Prinzip sind diese Daten doch dann auch da.
Die Daten fallen auf jeden Fall an.
Da stehen wir vor dem grundsätzlichen Problem, das mit Kartenzahlungen einhergeht, Privacy-mäßig.
Das ist insofern kein neues Problem. Die Frage ist jetzt natürlich,
wer bekommt darauf Zugriff.
Das, was ich bisher gesehen habe, sah so aus, dass Behörden darauf keinen Zugriff
haben auf die Transaktionshistorie und lediglich in Echtzeit das verfügbare
Guthaben einsehen können.
Das heißt, darüber ist natürlich immer noch Nachverfolgung möglich,
indem man da halt zum Beispiel regelmäßig nachfragt, wie viel Geld ist denn
jetzt eigentlich noch da und das könnte natürlich auch irgendwie zu unschönen Situationen führen,
wenn zum Beispiel, also du hast dein Geld jetzt irgendwie in der ersten Woche
alles ausgegeben, wo hast du das für ausgegeben, was machst du damit? damit.
Also, ja. Also, nur um das sozusagen, mein Kopf fängt dann immer an,
über Extremfälle nachzudenken.
Das heißt aber, es ist theoretisch möglich, ich lasse mir den Kontostand sekundengenau
ausgeben, dann weiß ich immer, wann Transaktionen stattgefunden haben und wenn
jemand mal 50 Euro ausgegeben hat und es war nachts, dann weiß ich,
okay, der hat wahrscheinlich doch Party gemacht, obwohl ich doch die Disco ausgeschlossen hatte.
Also, diese auch Metadaten sagen Dinge, das ist schon eine Sache,
die auch gefährlich sein könnte.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht groß anders als.
Ne, aber das ist meine nächste Frage. Für mein normales Konto gibt es sowas
wie ein Bankengeheimnis.
Auch da gibt es irgendwie Dinge, aber die Bank selber, die weiß natürlich sehr
viel über mich, aber mein Sachbearbeiter weiß halt nicht, was die Bank weiß.
Und das ist die Frage, nee, warte, ich rede jetzt von mir, Markus Richter.
Genau, okay, denke ich so. Aber wenn es anders wäre, dann gäbe es zumindest
Gesetze, auf die man sich beziehen könnte und so weiter und so fort.
Wie ist das hier? Ist das auch, also unterliegen die Daten für das Konto,
in Anführungszeichen, einer Bezahlkarte auch so eine Art Bankgeheimnis?
Oder ist es da eben doch sehr viel einfacher, auch wenn sie technisch gesehen
bei den meisten Vorschlägen, die Flippke gesehen hat, nicht Zugriff haben.
Aber es ist einfacher für Behörden, da ranzukommen.
Na, theoretisch ist es ein Konto. Also ich meine, es ist kein richtiges Konto.
Aber du hast so eine virtuelle IBAN, die die Menschen nicht kennen,
die das benutzen und so. Aber eigentlich... Aber ist das auch rechtlich halt?
Vermutlich. Also da steht halt das Problem ist, bei dieser Ausschreibung steht
halt nur drin, dass die sich an die Datenschutzregeln halten müssen, die üblichen.
Dieses mit dem Datenschutzgrundverordnung und Co. Da steht nicht konkret drin,
so ist es geregelt. Das heißt, ich vermute mal, das ist was,
was wir noch sehen werden.
Aber zumindest haben sie es nicht, also was mal gut ist, ist,
dass sie jetzt nicht defaultmäßig irgendwie gesagt haben, wir geben jetzt jeder
Sachbearbeitungsperson einmal im Monat eine Analyse, wo du so dein Geld ausgibst.
Ja, hat ja immer zwei Seiten. Es wird nicht konkret gefordert,
aber solange es nicht verboten ist, wird der Andrea was zu?
Also sie beabsichtigen es jedenfalls nicht, das zu machen. Und alle,
mit denen ich bisher gesprochen habe, haben gesagt, nein, nein,
die Sozialamtsmitarbeiterinnen kriegen auf gar keinen Fall dann Zugriff auf die Kontodaten.
Und ich habe mich auch mal unterhalten mit einem Anbieter und der hat gesagt,
das ist selbstverständlich nach Datenschutz so, dass die Ämter die Karte sperren
können, wenn es begründet ist.
Also bei Verlust und so weiter, aber nicht auf die einzelnen Transaktionen zugreifen
können oder reingucken können.
Allerdings, hat er gesagt, was sie natürlich machen könnten,
wäre sowas wie eine anonymisierte Auswertung.
Also sie könnten natürlich sämtliche Daten nehmen, die der Anbieter hat und
sagen, guck mal hier, der türkische Gemüsehändler in der Ecke hat halt doch
einen sehr, sehr hohen Umsatz.
Und da könnte das mal hingucken und sich überlegen, was verkauft der denn ganz
genau und kann man die nicht vielleicht auch aussperren über diese Liste oder
irgendwie sperren lassen.
Und sobald die Daten einmal da sind, also wo ein Druck, da die Schweine.
Also eventuell wird es dann so laufen, dass dann zu Forschungszwecken diese
Daten benötigt werden, um das Thema Flucht zu erforschen.
Da geht es dann selbstverständlich ausschließlich nur um aggregierte Daten.
Aber diese Daten fallen halt an und sind da. Und da ist halt ein Missbrauchspotenzial gegeben.
Auch wenn es jetzt in den Implementationen, die wir bisher so gesehen haben,
nicht danach aussieht, aber die Daten sind halt da und können halt zu allen
möglichen Zwecken eingesetzt werden und das ist definitiv problematisch.
Und die Anbieter sind halt eben keine Banken? Doch. Also in Europa ist ja alles
reguliert und Kartenzahlungsdienstleister natürlich auch.
Und feig sind das E-Geld-Institute, die solche Karten ausstellen können.
Das sind dann so Fintechs, die das als Dienstleistung anbieten.
Und die müssen da einen ganzen Berg an Regeln und Gesetzen einhalten und das
ist auch der Grund, warum man so was normalerweise irgendwie bei einem Fintech
einkauft und nicht selber macht.
Also so Kreditkarten ausgeben ist schon kompliziert. hat.
Ich glaube, ich weiß das schon fast genug über Bezahlkarten.
Ich habe jetzt noch drei Fragen und die erste davon ist, haben wir,
um das Konzept Bezahlkarte, wie es gerade politisch diskutiert wird,
zu verstehen, haben wir noch, was brauchen wir noch, was wichtig ist oder seid
ihr da schon alles los geworden, was man über dieses Ding sozusagen selber werden
muss? Wir können da kurz drüber nachdenken.
Die andere Frage ist nämlich sozusagen, ich muss mal ein bisschen platt und
flapsig formulieren, warum Andrea von Pro Asyl, die sich mit den Rechten für
Geflüchtete beschäftigt, mit einer Bezahlkarte beschäftigt.
Die für Klöchtergeld ist mir einleuchtend. Wenn ich jetzt mal doof frage,
Netzpolitik.org, okay, Politik im Namen, ein bisschen digital,
Flöbke, aber sozusagen Technik, hast du ja gesagt, das ist technisch nichts
Besonderes und auch nichts Anspruchsvolles.
Warum interessiert ihr euch dann so dafür?
Das ist mal wieder ein hervorragendes Beispiel hier dafür, dass man Technik
eben nicht immer nur aus einer technischen Perspektive betrachten darf,
wie das vielleicht manche Nerds irgendwie sich vom Kongress wünschen und dann
rummeckern, dass der Kongress ja viel zu politisch und viel zu untechnisch sei.
Sondern hier sieht man mal wieder, dass Technik halt auch immer mit Politik einhergeht.
Also wir haben hier einen ganzen Riesenberg an sozialen Fragen, die da mit dran hängen.
So die Technik ist halt langweilig. Das sind halt Kreditkarten,
da kann man sich reinnörten, wenn man sowas mag. Das ist sicherlich interessant.
Das ist ein über Jahrzehnte gewachsenes System, so Kreditkartenzahlungssysteme
und Abrechnungssysteme. Da kann man viel wierte Sachen drüber lernen und erfahren.
Da kann man sich eins allein nennen.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist es halt etwas, das schon lange gibt und wo es auch
Security Practices gibt.
Aber es ist halt aus politischer Perspektive interessant, weil hier Technik
eingesetzt werden kann und eingesetzt werden soll, um Menschen in ihren Rechten
zu beschränken, um Menschen zu drangsalieren.
Und deswegen ist das für mich interessant und ein Grund, weshalb ich mich damit damit beschäftige.
Und ja, also interessante Forschungsthemen könnten halt sein,
wie kann man so irgendwelche Beschränkungen umgehen natürlich.
Ich glaube, dass die Menschen da sehr kreativ werden in Zukunft,
wenn das eingeführt wird. Gemüsehändler der Welt, vereinigt euch!
Ja, genau. Also, dass wir da diverse Gemüsehändler sehen werden.
Interessant ist natürlich auch zu schauen, wie sieht es mit der Security aus,
aber wie gesagt, das ist halt ein ein,
bekanntes Gebiet, so Kreditkarten, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwas Neues.
Die Regierung ist jetzt nicht plötzlich nochmal mit einer Blockchain irgendwie
um die Ecke gekommen. Wieso eigentlich nicht?
Geflüchteten Geld-NFTs. Bietet sich doch total an, so Blockchains für irgendwelche
Zahlungsabwicklungen.
Vor allem, wenn dann noch irgendwie die Sachen dann alle öffentlich on-chain
drinstehen, wer wo Geld ausgegeben hat. Dann wird das mit dem Datenschutz auch gleich erledigt.
Anna, an dich auch die Frage, sozusagen. Es gibt jetzt im Chaos gerade mal ein
Vorbereitungspad. Die Hälfte dieses Pads sind Links zur Netzpolitik,
Org-Artikeln über Bezahlkarten. Warum?
Ich gebe jetzt mal so eine ganz egoistische Antwort, weil das ist halt so eines
der Themen, wo mein Blutdruck halt irgendwie zuverlässig so krass steigt. Also ich meine...
Ich beschäftige mich jetzt seit über zehn Jahren mit diversesten netzpolitischen
Themen und Vorhaben, die irgendjemand hat und die oft nicht ganz so klug sind.
Aber Bezahlkarten ist so ein Ding, wo ich mich richtig hart drüber aufrege,
weil es halt irgendwie niemandem groß was bringt und weil ich glaube,
man muss halt irgendwie so den Bullshit callen, wenn Leute irgendwie meinen,
sie haben irgendwie eine technische Lösung für ein soziales Problem gefunden.
Das aber in keiner Richtung irgendwie funktioniert.
Und ich glaube, das muss man halt irgendwie auch schreiben.
Und was mich besonders krass aufgeregt hat, ist, dass das eine uralte Idee ist.
Ich meine, das gab es in den 90ern schon mal.
Und ich meine, ich war in den 90ern im Kindergarten. Ich habe das damals nicht
live mitgekriegt und ich habe irgendwie zwei Stunden gebraucht,
um darauf zu stoßen und festzustellen, hey, das ist damals schon einfach hart
gescheitert und das hat damals irgendwie keinem geholfen.
Und jetzt wird die Scheiße wieder aus der Mottenkiste geholt und ich habe mir
so, du brauchst nicht viel, um rauszufinden, dass das wirklich nicht zu irgendwas führen wird.
Und ich reg mich halt darüber auf. Es ist einfach eine krasse menschenverachtende Nummer.
Es ist auch, wenn man irgendwie so in Verwaltungsdenke denkt,
es ist eine krasse Geldverschwendung, diese ganzen Anbieter irgendwie zu beauftragen,
eine Ausschreibung zu machen und diesen ganzen Hickhack.
Und dann nur dazu, um dann halt quasi populistisch irgendwie zu sagen,
wir tun jetzt was gegen die bösen Geflüchteten, damit nicht noch mehr Leute
nach Deutschland kommen.
Das ist halt so ein krasses im Braunen Fischen von irgendwie einer Regierung,
die eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, wir hatten ja mal so eine Ampelregierung,
die irgendwie meinte, hier Fortschrittskoalition und so, wie sie sich genannt haben.
Und was macht man da? Man fischt da, wo es halt irgendwie richtig,
richtig eklig wird und fällt dann irgendwie selber in so einen Sumpf rein. Ja.
Ich will noch die Anschlussfrage stellen, ist das auch oder anders,
wenn Technologie für repressive Zwecke eingesetzt wird, ist das manchmal so
ein Ausprobieren, bevor es sozusagen breiter ausgerollt wird.
Jetzt könnte man sich vorstellen, cool, die Geflüchteten, die sozusagen haben
viel besseres zu tun, als sich gegen Bezahlkarten zu wenden und sowieso keine
Ahnung von seinem Rechtssystem, weil sie eben damit zu tun haben,
hier anzukommen und überhaupt ein Leben zu organisieren.
Lass mal da ausprobieren und wenn das gut klappt, wie wäre es,
wenn wir die BürgergeldempfängerInnen auch mit Bezahlkarten ausstatten?
Ist das so? Und das ist natürlich zynisch, kann man sich das immer ausdenken.
Seht ihr hier auch die Gefahr, dass das der Anfang ist von Sozialleistungen
werden zunehmend über technisch abgestandene,
aber repressiv zu benutzendes Thema bezahlt?
Ausgerechnet oder damit verknüpft? Seht ihr das als Gefahr?
Oder ist das sozusagen wirklich so ein abgekoppeltes Feld?
Na, die Vorschläge gab es ja. Es gab ja mal ein paar, ich glaube,
ein paar CDU-Politiker vor allem, aber genau weiß ich es nicht,
die gesagt haben, wir brauchen das irgendwie für mehr Sozialleistungsarten.
Aber es ist irgendwie auch ein bisschen sinnlos. Ich meine, weil in der Regel
haben ja die Leute ein normales Konto.
Und du kannst damit ja... Ja, aber das kann man ja nicht so schön abschalten.
Ja, aber du kannst das doch total leicht umgehen. Also du kommst ja schon irgendwie
an Geld, das du dann auf dein normales Konto einzahlen kannst.
Das heißt, es ist ja irgendwie ein bisschen quatschig.
Also es bringt ja nicht viel. Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein ernsthaftes Ding wird tatsächlich.
Also irgendjemand wird es fordern und vielleicht führt es auch mal irgendjemand irgendwo ein.
Aber das wird glaube ich nicht relevant. Und ich glaube, wir sollten auch nicht
den Fehler machen, uns erst irgendwie drüber aufzuregen, wenn es dann irgendwie
den Herbert und die Marianne betrifft. so.
Ne, das wollte ich um Gottes Willen nicht damit gesagt haben.
Also ich wollte nur fragen, ob das, auf mich hat das jetzt einen Eindruck gemacht,
das ist tatsächlich ein Thema, das sozusagen nur für dieses Feld gefordert wird.
Aber es ist ja oft so, dass man, keine Ahnung, Z-Kontrolle, es geht halt nur
gegen das eine, aber dann geht es auf einmal doch irgendwie um alles andere.
Genau, es wurde auch für andere schon gefordert.
Also die Forderung ist schon da, das hat sich schon jemand einfallen lassen.
Also Asylsuchende stellen natürlich schon immer ein prima Experimentierfeld
dar, in der Hinsicht. Da probiert man halt viel mit aus, Da kann man es auch leicht machen.
Da sind die Leute sehr abhängig, sehr hilflos, besonders am Anfang, wenn sie kommen.
Insofern sehen wir das schon oft, dass da einfach Sachen durchprobiert werden,
die potenziell natürlich auch ausgeweitet werden können.
Klar. Dann Abschlussrunde. Und zwar,
wir haben jetzt sehr lange darüber geredet, warum die Motivation großer Bockmist
ist, was man daran alles kritisieren kann, warum es technologisch nicht so spannend
ist, aber trotzdem wichtig ist für Leute, die sich für Technik interessieren.
Ihr wart aber auch sozusagen schon relativ am Anfang so, es gibt schon die einen
relativ eng eingegrenzten Felder, wo das Sinn machen kann.
Jetzt ist immer die Frage, wenn so eine Technik oder Technologie die eher,
also vor allem eingesetzt wird, um damit Scheiß zu machen, aber es dieses eine
kleine enge Feld gibt, wo es vielleicht doch Sinn macht.
Wie sieht eure Traumvorstellung davon aus? Was ist jetzt mit diesem Ding Bezahlkarten?
Sollen wir das einfach komplett einstampfen?
Oder ist es realistisch dran zu arbeiten, dass man sagt, nee,
das funktioniert da gut, lass es mal da machen, aber den Rest bitte irgendwie
in der Versenkung verschwinden. Wie seht ihr das? Andrea, fangen wir mit dir an.
Also der politische Wille ist überhaupt nicht da, eine Bezahlkarte positiv zu nutzen.
Und die Grundidee, auch gerade einer flächendeckenden Bezahlkarte,
also einer bundeseinheitlichen, die sie ja anstreben, deswegen sich die Länder
ja zusammentun und gemeinsame Anforderungsliste schreiben und so,
diese Grundidee ist einfach eine abschreckende und die ist komplett abzulehnen.
Wenn es aber Städte gibt wie Hannover, die das so machen für eine Übergangszeit,
dann ist da überhaupt nichts gegen einzuwenden.
Da haben wir nichts dagegen, aber befördern würden wir es auch nicht,
weil wir andererseits die Gefahr sehen, dass es natürlich umschlägt und jederzeit
auch geändert werden kann.
Es ist halt ein Klick im Zweifelsfall, bis solche Beschränkungen dann eingeführt sind auf so einer Karte.
Aber das war ein bisschen meine Frage. Also würdest du sagen,
weil es diese Gefahr gibt, Bezahlkarte kategorisch nein?
Sagen wir nicht. Wir sagen nicht Bezahlkarte kategorisch nein.
Wir sagen, es gibt diesen Anwendungsspielraum in der Übergangszeit,
in dem man sie sinnvoll einsetzen kann.
Sie ist bloß nicht so gedacht und alles, was jetzt in Rede steht und was jetzt
verhandelt wird und alles das, was wir erwarten können, ist was gänzlich anderes,
als dass es den Leuten oder irgendwem was Gutes nützt, sondern das ist eine
reine Debatte, die andockt an Ressentiments.
Und arbeitet ihr schon an der Verfassungsklage oder wer macht das?
Ich sage mal so, es gibt ein paar einschlägige Sozialrechtler,
die sich sehr gut auskennen mit dem Thema, die alle schon in den Startlöchern
stehen und sehr gespannt sind, was da passiert.
Ganz einfach wird es dennoch nicht. Und was mich persönlich,
wenn ich das noch sagen darf, in der Abschlussrunde wirklich nachhaltig auch
beeindruckt, immer wieder negativ, ist, dass tatsächlich es so weit überhaupt kommen muss.
Also, dass man Politikern sagen muss, hier verstößt möglicherweise was gegen
Verfassungsrecht und es beeindruckt sie halt null. Null.
Und da wird mutwillig, und das erleben wir nicht zum ersten Mal im Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz,
aber auch überhaupt im Sozialrecht, auch bei deutschen Sozialhilfeempfängern,
dass Standards gesetzt werden, das Grundrecht was vorgibt, die Verfassung was
vorgibt und die Politik einfach sagt,
ja, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht.
Auch das, was die Wissenschaft jetzt sagt. Es gibt genug Argumente gegen diese
Scheinargumente. Wir haben uns gar nicht mit allen beschäftigt heute.
Mit diesem Poolfaktor haben wir uns beschäftigt. Gar nicht mit dem Argument,
dass die Leute das Geld in die Herkunftsländer schicken. Ist genauso so ein
Quatsch, dieses Argument.
Aber das, was die Wissenschaft dazu sagt, das interessiert sie einfach nicht.
Es wird einfach gemacht.
Und wir sind in einer Situation, wo Politiker auch auf die Straße gehen und
sagen, hallo, wir verteidigen hier unsere Verfassung, wir grenzen uns hier ab nach rechts.
Wir sind hier die Guten in dem ganzen Spiel und wo es trotzdem möglich ist,
dass die Verfassung ganz klare Vorgaben macht und die einfach mit Füßen getreten werden.
Man einfach darauf wartet, bis es das Gericht nochmal korrigiert.
Wir haben, wenn ich das noch sagen darf, Wir haben ein Verfassungsgerichtsurteil
im Oktober 2022 bekommen zum Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz.
Da geht es um Kürzungen für Alleinstehende in Gemeinschaftsunterkünften.
Da hat sich die Bundesregierung 2019 ausgedacht, die Leute, die alleine sind
oder alleinerziehend sind, in Gemeinschaftsunterkünften leben müssen,
dürfen sie sich ja nicht aussuchen, die können doch mit den anderen Alleinstehenden
so zusammen wirtschaften wie Ehepaare.
Die können doch ihr Geld zusammenschmeißen. Und deswegen kriegen sie auch nur
einen Partnerbetrag. Deswegen kriegen sie zehn Prozent weniger.
Nochmal von den ohnehin schon reduzierten Leistungen. Das ist eine Regelung,
die hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht im Oktober 2022 für verfassungswidrig erklärt.
Diese Regelung ist bis heute nicht umgesetzt.
Das Sozialministerium hat zwar gesagt, ja, das müsste umgesetzt werden.
Und das müsste auch jetzt in allen Ländern umgesetzt werden und für die gesamte
betroffene Personengruppe. Aber es passiert nicht, weil die Länder sagen,
es ist ja im Gesetz noch gar nicht geändert.
Die Länder setzen es schon um, aber die Kommunen setzen es zum großen Teil nicht um.
Vielerorts ist es einfach definitiv immer noch so, nach anderthalb Jahren nach
dem Verfassungsgerichtsurteil, dass Menschen mit gekürzten Leistungen leben.
Rechtswidrig anerkanntermaßen, rechtswidrig gekürzten Leistungen leben müssen,
weil die Bundesregierung zwar das Asyl-BLG zuletzt im Februar verschärft hat,
aber es angefasst hat, aber diese verfassungswidrige Regelung noch immer nicht ausgestrichen hat.
Und da frage ich mich, wie kann das eigentlich sein, wenn sie gleichzeitig mit
breiter Brust sich hinstellen und sagen, wir stehen hier für die Demokratie ein.
Und das finde ich daran schockierend. Ich will noch kurz einen Punkt sagen,
weil du gerade sagst, wir hätten nicht über die Pull-Faktoren gesprochen.
Das klang vorhin kurz an, dem wurde aber sozusagen eine relativ kräftige Halbsatzwatsche
erteilt, sodass ich dachte, wir müssen gar nicht mehr weiter darüber reden.
Aber du sagst, es ist nicht nur sozusagen die pragmatische Überlegung,
sondern es ist auch wissenschaftlich belegt, dass das Quatsch ist.
Ja, naja, ich dachte, die Abschreckung schon, Pullfaktor ja,
aber dieses Argument, das hatte ich auch nicht genannt.
Das Geld würde ja an die Familien in Herkunftsländern geschickt.
Das wird ja immer noch gerne vorgebracht, um die Bezahlkarte zu rechtfertigen,
damit keine Überweisungen ins Ausland möglich sind. Und das ist aber genau so ein Quatsch.
Müssen wir auch nicht lange drüber reden.
Es gibt genug wissenschaftliche Belege dafür, dass das einfach nicht richtig
ist. Aber auch das interessiert sie nicht.
Es wird gemacht, weil es gemacht werden soll, weil es in die Stimmung passt.
Damn, Flüppke, alles anzünden oder doch den einen guten Anwendungszweck irgendwie etablieren?
Ja doch, also wenn Menschen hierher kommen und erstmal kein Geld haben,
um sich was zu essen, was zu trinken zu kaufen, ist es total sinnvoll,
den Menschen etwas in die Hand zu drücken.
Ob das nun Bargeld oder eine Karte ist, ist mir persönlich relativ egal.
Egal, aus technischer Perspektive ist es auf jeden Fall nicht ganz so großer
Bullshit wie andere Projekte, die wir da so in der Vergangenheit gesehen haben.
Es ergeben sich natürlich diverse Risiken aus den Daten, die da anfallen und
Missbrauchspotenziale aus der technologischen Umsetzung und natürlich sehr viele Repressalien,
die darüber umgesetzt werden können.
Das heißt, es kommt hinterher sehr auf die Ausgestaltung drauf an.
Und da die PolitikerInnen da ja mit einer sehr repressiven Grundhaltung in diese
ganze Debatte reingehen, erwarte ich nicht, dass das in irgendwas Sinnvollem
oder Brauchbarem münden wird.
Und deswegen denke ich, dass es sinnvoll ist, das abzulehnen und zu schauen,
was man da irgendwie reißen kann.
Aber dieses Thema, dafür eine Öffentlichkeit zu erzeugen, ist halt auch ein
bisschen schwierig, weil die meisten Menschen, so irgendwie mein Eindruck,
sich wenig für die Rechte von Asylbewerbern interessieren.
Da kann eventuell, wenn man sich doch mit der Technik da auseinandersetzt,
wenn man da irgendwie Schwachstellen oder sowas findet, irgendwelche Leaks oder
sowas, damit kann man natürlich eine Öffentlichkeit erzeugen.
Aber das, ja, ansonsten ist das halt so aus technischer Perspektive relativ
langweilig und es kommt ganz darauf an, wie das hinterher konfiguriert wird,
welche Einschränkungen da reingehackt werden, was man damit machen darf und was nicht.
Und da sehe ich schwarz. Okay, Anna?
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, wir können es einfach lassen und die Energie,
die man darauf verwendet, einfach für sinnvollere Dinge einsetzen und uns was
ausdenken, wie wir das Leben von den Leuten vielleicht ein bisschen besser machen
können, anstatt irgendwie jetzt über die Details einer Bezahlkarte,
wie die denn sein müsste,
damit es okay ist, irgendwie zu streiten.
Weil wir können uns mit den Datenschutzfragen beschäftigen, wir können uns mit
den einzelnen Abhebelimits beschäftigen, wir können uns aber auch irgendwie
damit beschäftigen, wie machen wir das denn,
dass die Leute irgendwie von Anfang an irgendein würdiges Leben haben und da
haben wir glaube ich größere Diskussionspunkte als eine Plastikkarte.
Es scheint mir sozusagen, es ist sozusagen, wenn man sich in die deutsche Politiklandschaft
begibt, gerade nicht opportun, wenn man als seriösliche DiskussionspartnerInnen
gelten will, zu sagen, nein, das ist alles totaler Quatsch.
Sondern man muss halt eben sagen, ja, es gibt dieses eine Beispiel,
aber im Subtext nehme ich schon wahr, im Prinzip würden wir uns gerne überhaupt
gar nicht mehr mit dem Thema beschäftigen, sondern wie du gerade gesagt hast,
lasst die Leute, deren Leben eh schon schlimm genug ist, lasst uns das Leben
einfach einfacher und angenehmer gestalten.
Puh, vielen lieben Dank euch das war heute wieder sehr deprimierend es tut mir
sehr leid, liebe HörerInnen dass ich euch,
nicht fröhlicher entlassen kann Flübke, Anna und Andrea vielen lieben Dank,
dass ihr das so ausführlich und gut erklärt habt, liebe Leute ihr wisst,
was ihr zu tun habt, alles anzünden und ansonsten nur noch die eine andere Sache
die ich euch immer mit auf den Weg gebe ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen und
verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups, tschüss.
Music.